final fantasy 14 is still going strong
and the next big batch of content is on
the way I'm Tony and this is your
expanded GameSpot news update final
fantasy xiv s next expansion is called
storm blood and it takes players to the
land of al amigo to battle the evil
xenos director producer Naoki Yoshida
said storm blood is bringing a quote
full standalone games worth of content
so you can expect plenty of new areas
dungeons raids quests gear jobs and a
fourth residential area
the expansion arrives alongside update
4.0 which raises the level cap from 60
to 70 and revamps the battle system the
inventory system is also greatly
expanding but this may launch separately
from update 4.0 due to technical
requirements finally it's important to
note that support for the ps3 version of
ff14 will end with this update and PC
minimum specs will be increasing storm
blood is slated for release in early
summer 2017 on ps3 ps4 and PC it'll be
the MMO second full expansion after
2015's heavens wort you can expect more
trailers and information to trickle out
so keep an eye on GameSpot as we get
closer to release and for all the
biggest final fantasy news you're
already in the right place
you